Eric Voss here with another new  Rockstar's hot take about Glass Onion  and knives out mystery spoilers ahead  the first half of the movie actually  gives us all the clues we need in plain  sight as to what's really going on and  what miles really did you can see Duke's  phone showing Andy's obituary when miles  hugs him and Duke hides his phone from  birdie when she tries to look you can  see miles pouring Duke's drink and then  hand the glass directly to him and after  Duke dies when his phone dings miles  backs away when Peg approaches him and  he can see the phone sticking out of his  pocket as he runs away and then during  the blackout Montage when Helen is  hiding for a mom in the hallway as the  lighthouse light passes through you can  clearly see Duke's gun in his hand this  is all in the first hour of the movie  before the truth is revealed or we  should say re-revealed watch my full  breakdown for all the cool visual  details that you might have missed